a lot of cleansing bars make your eyes  go blurry the blurriness comes from the  oil this is pretty unavoidable because  all cleansing balms have oils you can  try to reduce it though by just closing  your eyes really tightly stinging is a  lot more avoidable it probably comes  from the surfactants or the fragrance or  maybe some other ingredient but  different products use different  ingredients so you might be able to find  one that doesn't sting depending on how  sensitive your eyes are the other option  is to just use a completely different  product for removing eye makeup my  favorites are these two layer makeup  removers i find that they remove my eye  makeup really easily this one doesn't  cause any blurriness or stinging for me  but i've also had some in the past that  did make my eyes go blurry and made my  eyes feel a bit dry so you might have to  try a few before finding the right one